uh Dakota lakes research
Farm you know one of the things as I go
through today I think I I really want
you guys to think about where you want
to be in a 100 years because you've got
to get in gear and get the agricultural
research system working to get you
there if we if we had the system we have
now if we' have had that 30 years ago we
would not have Dakota lakes and you
wouldn't know any of this
stuff okay so you really need to start
paying attention to what's happening at
all the land grant universities in the
United States because they're just
totally
being taken
over and and it really isn't applied
research a lot of it so there's the CES
research Farm it's owned by Farmers both
irrigated and dry land we've been 100%
low disturbance snow till um production
Enterprise profit supports the research
and that's why we've been able to
continue if you're not a member of
Dakota lakes you should
be if you haven't visited Dakota
lakes you should I have people from all
over the world come to visit us there
and they have a lot of people in South
Dakota never been there which is kind of
interesting uh and we're building an
addition on our shop so if you want to
really get involved you could make a
donation to that so there's our native
vegetation this is one of the most
exciting days I've
had my time at Dakota lakes this is not
quite a year ago January last year this
is Colin SC he's from Australia he's a
green and grays guy I've talked about
it's kind of a perennial cover cropping
system in Australia that works really
well this is Ralph derps I think a
couple people mentioned Ral uh he's from
Paraguay and this is durug Goan we call
him duracel cuz he always goes these
from Brazil as well and they came
through now these guys you notice Brazil
Paraguay and Australia was about 23
below that day and they wanted to take a
picture by the sign because they'd come
to the Dakota lakes research farm so
they wanted the sign so we're standing
out there we found all the coats we
could and then we went out and showed
them some of what we did this is
irrigated corn on corn we plant between
the cornrows uh we'll do a 2-year stack
and then and then this past year we
planted canola right in this little spot
here
uh and we dug around uh dersu is much
more excited than Ral and and you notice
Colin isn't even there he's in the damn
truck he's had enough of
this okay so a little bit of
biodiversity growing there um anyway
1979 I've shown you this before the
average wheight
price in in in in 1970 is $137 the
average price of Bar Oil was $3.39
so you just do the math for today it's
about 89 bucks for a barrel of oil today
uh but n bucks for wheat Minnesota where
tillage is King it takes slightly under
10 gallons of diesel fuel prak for
tillage seating and
harvest so that's not a lot four bucks a
gallon that's 40 bucks it's not a big
input if you're looking at price of land
in Minnesota for for whatever so uh to
take no till is not about taking out the
energy cost it takes the energy one
gallon diesel fuel to manufacture
transport to pipe 5 lounds of
nitrogen so that Minnesota farmer puts
on 150 pounds of AC per acre of an the
energy is three times 30 gallons they
had to use for tillage seeding and
harvest so the big energy input is
nitrogen
fertilizer the big problem with doing
tillage is it screws up all the things
these guys talked about had one guy come
up and said boy you're how conventional
tiller you're really making us
conventional tillers feel bad and
whatever and I said well you better go
home before
[Laughter]
so 80% of the total input cost in
agriculture can be traced directly to
energy we all feel really good about how
we how good a farmers we are 80% of
that's due to energy 120 years ago that
was Zero
120 years from now it has to be zero
again because we're going to be out of
fossil
fuels now some people say I'm going to
use
biodiesel if we took and we are cold
pressing our oil seeds and stuff right
at the farm because we're going to be
fossil fuel neutral by 2026
but if I took all the oils and fats in
the United
States beef Tallow pork lard all the
corn oil soybean oil and whatever and
made them into b00 we would have about
20% of our road diesel plus home heating
needs and that's it we'd have nothing
for agriculture nothing for electrical
generation nothing for
industrial and we still need 80% it's
not the answer
okay it's a way for us to have diesel
fuel in case we can't get it to run our
combines but it's not a long-term
solution so I'm a farmer I take sunlight
water and carbon dioxide and make them
into products I can sell you notice I
didn't say anything about energy and
iron and whatever how well do we do this
one of the things we do is we get hung
up on these terms Randy England was over
here running all these terms by I mean I
had this put together already Randy and
they sat there and smiled at you
right sustainable no till regenerative
organic zero Tails Drex seed what the
hell you want to call yours
R I don't know yeah I got another name
right the new one is soil
Health okay but you have a hell of a
time defining that too we had nrcs had a
whole soil health Team right remember
all the boys out in Colorado they showed
up one day and they're trying to write a
definition this is what you do got to do
to have a healthy soil you got to and
you and I took them out of one of my
fields and I dug up a little soil I said
smell
this and they smelled it and they said
now you know if you get something that
measure that smell that would
work but I also challenged him I said
define a beautiful woman or a handsome
man how tall how what size hair what
color hair what size different things
right you can't write a definition for
but we all know one when we see one
okay mine mine happens we had 20 our
25th wedding anniversary about two weeks
ago she needs a sympathy card not a not
an one I get a really kick out of it I
was traveling in Canada last year they
came up with this turb ethical
oil it means that the oil from Canada
even though they they dig it out of the
tar Sands and heat the he 11 hell out of
it and do all this stuff at
least their
women are well
treated and they get educations and
whatever whereas in some of the Saudi
the the Eastern Middle Eastern Nations
they aren't treated as well right and
they have human rights and whatever so
thorough oil is better it's ethical
oil and I'm yeah
okay that
works okay we spend lots of time trying
to find what we should do and should not
do and little time focusing on where we
want to
be where do you want to
be consequently much of the research and
management effort is devoted to
optimizing a single component like
canola or corn you know how can you
better manage what how can you kill that
what event do you have in that corn and
when you're resistant to that corn you
got to get another
event right spend all this time looking
at these little tiny
details and we're using more and more
specialized treatment we're really
focusing on the end instead of acting to
get where we want to be we're
reacting reacting from
going where we do not want to be be
instead of focusing on where we want to
be it's a little bit like trying to
drive your car Down The Highway by
looking at the edge of the
ditch okay that works in a blizzard for
you boys from the south that don't
really understand how to drive in a
blizzard
Ray see all these South Dakota guys know
how to do
this when you're drunk driving a blizard
in the old days it's really fun
but it's not ideal way to get
home now there's no better time than now
we've never been more
profitable you know I can tell by all
the four-wheel drive pickups around
people have some spare cash right so
where do we want to be where do you want
South Dakota to be in 200
years what do you want to look like we
keep doing what we're doing what's it
going to look like
okay so what 30 years of noil and crop
ration work have taught me remember that
I'm a slow
learner if you don't believe that ask my
wife I've learned more from Farmers than
they have learned from me and I've learn
more from Farmers because they call me
up and
say how would you do this or I did this
and this happened and my advantage is
I've talked to a lot of farmers that
have made a lot of mistakes and we all
learned
and I've also had 30 years to make
mistakes of my own I've learned more
from observing nature than trying to
change
it and I gave a talk last
spring at SDSU to a bunch of really
young faculty members that don't know
South Dakota about where Dakota lakes
came
from and I started with the LA Andre
Brothers how many people here know who
the LA Andre brothers are yeah people
from real Pier do
okay they are the French fur Traders
sons from Winnipeg that came across the
Continental Divide from the Red River
Valley to the the Missouri River Valley
looking for a Westward passage and also
to claim this area for France and the
reason we bought it in the Louisiana
Purchase from France were those guys but
they're also looking for
beavers and then Lewis and Clark we
looking for beavers to kill and once we
killed the Beavers we no longer had the
beaver that kept the water from flooding
the Missouri
River and white man wasn't smart enough
to build his houses up on the Hills they
build them in the river
bottoms and we start flooding so then we
had to build big ass
dams and we built the dams we had to
take water
from
Pier to
Redfield to irrigate because you
couldn't possibly grow corn and soybeans
in the gim rer Valley without irrigation
duh
right I've learned more from observing
nature them prying to change it I
thought hell we can do this we can grow
corn so in Jimmer
Valley if we know till we can grow corn
at Pier if we no
till if we better use the water because
Mother Nature could do just fine doing
that noil is just one tool among many
that we use to help us manage our
ecosystem but if we do tillage we got
everything so screwed up we can't manage
it anymore so the first step had to be
quit doing
tillage and then you do adjust all these
other things and you guys have seen this
before but a lot of guys just quit doing
tillage didn't change anything else oh
we're just going to do corn beans like
we always did and it
collapses okay so cultural practices
technology and
management we have to till
is a cultural practice we have to
replace it with other cultural practices
not
with technology technology is fine but
if you try to replace what you did with
tillage with only technology there's not
enough technology
available if it were available we
couldn't afford
it you know it's not available because
we get resistant if it were available we
couldn't afford it and if it even if it
were available we could afford it you
got to sell it to the consumer and they
frankly don't want us doing
that nature tillage is a catastrophic
event so when we take it out let's do
this rotation sanitation comp
competition proper intensity using this
water and cover crops is part of that
adequate
diversity Mother Nature tends to produce
lots of diversity when giving her way
and we try
to Crunch this down to do one or two
species and she's trying to have all
this diversity we're just going against
what she's trying to do and trust me
she's had several million years of doing
this and no matter what them Jean
jockies at SDSU think she's better at it
than they
are
okay and so they can keep doing it
that's fine but she's just going to say
oh oh I see what you're up to here try
that and if we can get this part right
then we're going to be stable and
sustainable the other way to look at it
is water cycle Are We Cycling the water
the way it was cycled before we start
farming if not we're leaking
stuff and we're leaking nutrients out
and they're going like Ray said to the
golf for
Mexico or whatever okay if we put drain
tile in we really screw these up energy
flow how much of the energy that's
falling there are we catching I'm going
to Manitoba tonight they used to do
summerow last week I was in Montana with
with Paul and they still do summerow
what percentage if they're doing spring
wheat summer fallow what percentage of
the sunlight that falls on the ground in
two years do they catch well everything
from May June and July why one year out
of two 3 months out of
24 not very
good and Community Dynamics what happens
with how many species do you have there
farmers and ranchers Harvest sunlight
carbon dioxide and water right some of
this is human food we need to be aware
of nutritional issues and offsite
impacts when you raise food in different
ways wheat for instance it has different
qualities people are starting to become
interested in that Cod Lakes right now
is having long discussions with the
people who buy buy Grain and things for
kog and Kashi and Starbucks and whatever
based on this factor and they initiated
it not us if we want to eat beef that's
great maybe we should concentrate on
producing beef instead of trying to grow
corn and barley that feeds beef and feed
Lots know just if we all want to grow
some beef out here let's figure out how
the best way to do that weeds and
diseases are Mother Nature's Way of
adding diversity to system that lacks it
so the more you try to concentrate on
one species the more she's going to try
to offer Alternatives nothing new you've
seen these before for me savings might
be expected in the amount of fertiliz
and irrigation water used in a
three-year rotation he's talking about
wheat because of healthy or more
functional root systems that could be
corn when you have a drought year like
this
year was your plant root
healthy was it in a healthy soil that
had all these macropores so it could
explore the whole root
Zone because that's part of what has to
happen biological control of soil and
residue inhabiting past of weed is
accomplished by not growing eat more
frequently than every third year second
or third year a change in cultural
practices not pay may not pay off at
first one or two years R was talking
about that might take a while so did
Paul but we'll pay off in
time each future wheat field or corn
field is treated to the extent possible
as an ecosystem to be nudged rather than
shocked in a desired
Direction right now everybody's trying
to shock the thing we throw this
fungicide on but that kills his
beneficials and if you put fungicide on
there F fungus is what the earthworms
eat bad ones and good ones so you're
going to starve them to
death we haven't used an insecticide at
Dakota Lake in 12
years not because I'm saying gee we
don't want to use insecticide because we
don't have to we have predators we use
some seed treatments and things but we
don't use the high rate Cruis and stuff
either it kills our
Predators the shest
way for me to guarantee that I'd have to
use a poster insecticide is to put some
insecticide with my herbicide just
because it only costs a
buck
okay crop rotation is the single most
critical Factor affecting the health and
productivity of future crops in general
crop ation allows time for natural
enemies to destroy the pathogens of one
crop while unrelated crops are growing
this is not hard choose a sustainable
economic approach that optimizes
productivity while taking maximum
advantage or at least not getting in the
road of Mother Nature's contribution to
the health of a
crop over Reliance on herbicides leads
to resistant
weights and maybe disease
problem is there anybody in this room
that was in Denver in 1994 at monsanto's
Big conference out there where I did the
clothes 1994 I did the closing talk in a
Monsanto conference in Denver 2,000
people and I predicted Roundup
resistance I have the
tape not a popular position to take in a
Monsanto conference in
1994 it's simple you hadn't know that
was going to happen unless you were just
totally brain dead monsano knew they
were just hoping that their patent ran
out before it happened and it's not
their problem it's your problem it's
because we misused it right and maybe
disease problems if we use
surfactants too frequently may increase
disease issue have we seen an increase
in bacterial blight and goss's we
those used to be associated with hail
and wind and
things which weaken the LA wax on the
leaves but if we go out and
spray Fung surfactants with fungicide
surfactants with herbicides surfactant
with whatever we weaken the wax on the
leaves makes it easier for the bacteria
get in there it also kills beneficial
bacteria that attack fungi in
Saskatchewan they found that if they
spray fungicides early on wheat they
increase the amount of ferium because
because they kill a beneficial fungi
early go the web it's there been
published real science fungicides and
insecticides cause collateral damage
they are
disturbance just like anything else so
we're going to use them but we're going
to try to use them judiciously so we
look at some other things like chloride
soil testing
can be used to minimize the need for
early SE seasoned fungicide if you have
a chloride deficiency it makes you
susceptible to Le spotting
diseases rotation interval and weeds if
we want to prevent weeds this is U if
you have a resistant weed 10 of them
here with 10 seeds per per weed and you
do a rotation that's every other year
like corn Bean you have 10 million of
them in seven
years and that's assuming that you kill
it during the bean year so Roundup
resistance this doesn't count that's
more like a whatever if I go two years
out it never happens if I'm going to do
half corn and half beans I'd be better
off to do a stack where I do two corns
two
beans
okay here's a study that we did years
ago where we did 12 years of different
rotations on the 13th year I just
planted the whole thing to Spring
week and Randy Anderson from ARS came
out and he counted the weeds that came
up okay so we he counted the weeds we
sprayed sprayed round up and then we
planted our spring wheat and then we
just didn't put any more herbicide on he
counted the wheat where we had wheat
chickpea and that's could be corn
soybean if you want to he had 94 weeds
per square yard wheat corn chickp 40 P
wheat corn soybean more diversity
7 Now High disturbance techniques
increase web pesture and cause tillage
erosion this is 97% weed control by the
way with no
herbicide case you case you're wondering
uh High disturbance techniques increase
weed pressure and cause tillage erosion
he did the same count
in a tilled site with a two crop
rotation there's 225 versus 94 four crop
rotation 7 versus 44 this is due to the
tillage causing more weed somebody
talked about that earlier today was it
you right yeah God he's good isn't
he worth all the money we spent getting
him
here no you're not we're all taxpayers
we
all we all paid for you to come here I
knew you were going to say that you you
may be cheap but you're not free
right till age dist servance and poor
rotation 225 weeds per square meter no
till good rotation 7 there's your
97% weed control tillage was good at
eliminate weeds the damn thing should be
all gone by
now especially in Iowa and Illinois
right best weed
is a good crop canopy we keep this old
crop canopy in place or a cover crop
canopy or anything like that in place
until a new crop canopy
forms that's one of the things with a
cover crop you just go out there and put
another crop canopy there instead of
trying to kill it with a nervous
ey this one we had an a to
steer we have an auto steer now but this
is when we had an ought to UT to steer
better and
and you you don't pull in straight but
this is no herbicide on
wheat with a with a spot there that's
left and no competition that's what you
want to be able to see but there's
tillage
erosion we took the dirt from here
pulled it down here started out looking
like this then it medium term it's got
this bear that's about where we're at if
we keep doing that we're going to take
the CRA happy soil and cover up the good
soil down the
bottom and we're all going to use
variable rate technology so we fertilize
the top of the hill and drag the
down the bottom down
here now in Canada they do bail grazing
they put their Bales up here and turn
the cows out and the cows poop and eat
and whatever and you restore fertility
and organic matter back to top of the
hill it makes a lot of sense it put put
a fence around the Bales really kind of
a good system sanitation rotation and
competition are the primary methods of
pth
control herbicides are part of
competition they're part of Sanitation
they're part of rotation they're I don't
use herbicides for Pest
Control I use them as Tools in this
other little goal pesticides are only
part of these fertilizer placement
residue distribution are part of
competition going Place some fertilizer
maybe move a little residue we're much
less gung-ho about moving residue them
before but if I put my crop here and I
put fertilizer there and nothing out
here then my weeds don't have a chance
so again I can get this guy going before
these guys have any nice warm conditions
and before they get any
fertilizer this guy's got to learn to
drive on the other side of the field so
this blows
away if you get a 45 foot head from
somebody like John Deere and say you
know if you make a head 45 foot wide you
should make a thing in the back that
spreads it out 45
ft right should be a requirement we use
a lot of stripper heads for that reason
John Deere hasn't figured that out
neither's anybody
else place a fertilizer you know strip
Tail's hot but basically it's a
fertilizer placement thing and here's
that bar that somebody was talking about
today this is the cheap bar just now
some guys want corn heads that chop it
all
up and whatever but then it blows away
and floats away you leave it tall and
you use this thing to lean it over put a
little fertilizer and plant this is Mike
Arn's planter from whatever so what we
do is some s pee with the seed other
nutrients place near the row at seeding
time or on the soil Surface after crop
canopy if you broadcast fertilizer
before at seating it encourages
weeds three key factors available
nutrient moisture and Roots all three in
the same place the same
time and Ray Ward will tell you how much
available nutrient you have there
estimate it give you his best
guess how many of you guys know Ray
wart yeah okay do you know that he got
PhD from
SDSU he used to run the soil testing lab
his major professor and his PhD was the
same guy as my major Professor he ran
the Redfield farm at one time we're like
twins
okay maybe
not he's hell a lot better looking than
I am okay we don't kill our coyotes they
can't figure out why everybody wants to
kill their damn coyotes they eat they
eat
mice we don't kill our rattlesnakes
right one of the reason we kill a
rattlesnakes is somebody who does
organic
comp and they say well you're using
these terrible chemicals and I said well
what's what do you use we only use
natural stuff it's not dangerous it's
good I got rattlesnake need to move cuz
he's not going to hurt you obviously he
might cuz it's
natural proper nutrient cycling is
important ecosystems that leak nutrients
for extended periods of time become
deserts if you ship your wheat out and
don't bring
back the
nutrients in terms of fertilizer
you have a desert you're exporting
you're leaking we had a Taiwanese Randy
was there right had this time when need
trade delegation one of the things about
being close to Pier right were just
handy for these trade delegations they
got meet with the governor and they got
to stall them for an hour and a half so
let's go see some wheat we're going to
sell you wheat so
I'm talking to him and I got this wheat
coming up and the cover crop is dying
and I'm talking about how it's feeding
the nutrients the wheat and everything
and the guy goes oh you don't need to
use fertilizer and he said well yeah I
do need to ferti use fertilizer if I'm
going to ship you the wheat to Ty pay
because I'm sh shipping you nutrients
unless you're willing to take the poop
from Tai pay put it in a container and
ship it
back and he got this real stunned look
on his face and I okay I started a
diplomatic problem
here and then all of a sudden he gets it
and he starts laughing and he translates
and then they're all making a little
Scoopy sailing seeps are symptoms of
improper nutrient water
cycling if it wasn't salty when it was
in the prairie it's you'd done something
nutrient placement is part of cycling
try to make it go into the
plant developing proper water cycling
information is important you need to
know soil's water holding capacity
characteristics long rainfall and
covering forage crops are useful to help
fine tunes so here's my North unit Pier
Shale Drive promised soil and opal
soils uh pretty crappy don't hold much
water went to web soil survey which you
have in the United States how many
people have been to web soil survey
good good on you go home go to web soil
survey get a map this is coro's Bucking
Horse pasture if if you're watching the
National Finals you see my
neighbors you know CU corco takes my
neighbors takes them to Las Vegas and I
don't get to go and this shows you how
much available water holding capacity
this is three in this is 5 in total
water holding capacity in that really
heavy soil it's like a sand with a
really bad
attitude there I use cover crops a lot
because it gets full very quickly I'm
not going to talk about a lot of what we
do there there's a main Farm there's my
good soils that's about 12
in available water holding capacity okay
those are my good soils then we take
some place like Onida which is kind of
dry there's your rainfall from October
to September I use October one to
September take the E out of ET yeah Paul
I know you can't get it all out of there
but it sounds better you know taking
take part of the E out of ET you can't
take it all out I'm
so from October to June from the time
you would harvest corn until sunflowers
would start using water Onida way the
hell out there gets 10.36 in of rainfall
if you make it go in the ground and you
keep it
there and you have a promis soil you're
saturated and you're getting saine seeps
and you're
screwed now if you have a good soil if
you were way dry when you harvested the
corn which you usually
aren't you're going to be we full okay
so you can do that kind of exercise half
of normal is usually a drought this year
is a little bit more than half a little
less than half a normal and then this is
one and a half that wet year okay and
you can do that for different time
periods right the long phow the wheat
long phow they used to do it a Ida one
crop of winter wheat every two years
they tried to put 24 in of rain into
soils that hold somewhere between 7 to
12 is there any wonder they had sailing
seeps duh no till does make saine seeps
worse because it makes the water go in
the ground unless you do something
beneficial with that water why is land
sell for more in Iowa than it does in
South
Dakota they get more
rain but yet we have guys here trying to
get rid of their water
so if you put this rain in here with no
till you got to use it here or it
becomes a saine SE here and what's in a
saine
seat
Ray calcium salts what else is in there
sulfur is that a
fertilizer and calcium's a like lime
yeah what's the other one that's in
there chloride chloride oh we use that
for fertilizer yeah nitr nitrates do we
use that for a
fertilizer yeah who said
salt but it's these really good
salts sometimes you get a little
sodium but most of the time what's in
there is the good guys your fertilizers
that you're paying the hefes for and
what they really want to do is get you a
drain tile so you can get that damn
stuff gone quicker so they can sell you
more
[Applause]
duh cover and forage crops provide
opportunity increase both intensity and
diversity in situation where production
of grain crop would not be
possible so where you can't do a double
crop like the guys in Kansas you start
doing some of this stuff and add
biological diversity in human
environments tall grass prair or weather
which is kind of here in
East the goal should be have something
growing all
times where we have limited growing
season this will require use of cover
crops and forage crops or double crops
so that's here you don't have a long
enough season like the guys in Kansas in
subhuman to the west of here semi Aid
environments cover crops are utilized
less actually but it gives us a chance
to add organic matter and biological
activity sometimes we have to keep our
powder dry uh so here we're adding
carbon this is going to go to beans next
year versus not doing anything so here's
stripped wheat stubble here's adding hay
Millet and oats in there and then here
we have some feed that we can graze for
our tall cows and our short cows
uh I like that
joke uh now here's a real mixture of
stuff and that's what we look for is
this diversity they grow at different
times we'll start with like cow peas and
the brassas and the lentils and the cow
peas will grow early when it's hot and
then when it gets to be first night it's
36 they go oh damn this isn't Oklahoma
and they just die and then you got the
next step same way with the forage torgs
I use oats and forage torgs and the and
and the hay millets and when they get it
gets too cool for them they die and the
oats comes so that's what we looking for
is filling these different Niche so
there's there's a cowy that comes early
this stuff back here I actually got this
in the wrong order this comes later
okay does it work kind of here's a study
we did where we had a a cover crop of
lenel chickp uh chickling vetch and
turnup between a wheat a wheat wheat
corn corn soybean soybean so right in
here between the wheat and the first
corn if we put no nitrogen on the next
spring we got 176 belel of corn with 36
lbs of nitrogen we got 236 bush corn was
72 lb we got
214 no sometimes you get you know what
we got to do is start figuring out how
to predict that's going to happen but
the good thing in South Dakota
is if I want to use this nitrogen I cons
soil test and I'll have it again next
year just get it in the pool it doesn't
hurt to have it there so this is what I
call Catch and Release nutrients and a
lot of people use this and we should
give the credit for that to Jeremy
Wilson from Jamestown North
Dakota really good young no tail farmer
from Jamestown North Dakota and he used
this term and I walked up after he' used
it at a meeting I said Jeremy can I use
that oh sure he didn't know that
everybody else is going to start using
it right so anyway we need to
acknowledge that if you get stranded in
rain in the back 40 you drive home
across a child a tilled field or
pasture that's that soil structure thing
that Jim Horman talked
about okay it doesn't get there if you
do tillage every other year or whatever
okay but at least some components of a
rotation do not fail in excessively dry
years it's an indicator there's not
sufficient
intensity so if you failed on something
this year you did
good okay some of us did better than
others the rotation does
not but I'll give you an example we we
do a third of our Dryland corn at Pier
in soybean or sunflower
residue a
third because I call my mother-in-law
corn or my banker
corn because they come to visit in
June that's my corn that looks good and
then two-thirds of my Corn's in wheat
stubble and if my banker comes in
September or August I to show them the
stuff in wheat stubble right but in a
good year
that's my cheapest corn in soing
stubble I don't have to maintain the
wheat stubble right I just harvest the
beans the first thing the spring I plant
the
corn that's it pretty easy to manage
last year I had 140 bushel corn there
this year I had zero on average we're
about
110 okay that's okay it's not as
consistent as the stuff in wheat stubble
but if I don't fail in the really dry
year I haven't taken full advantage of
this normal year when I get 108
bushel and I fail badly in wet years and
that's what a lot of us did early on
we're so afraid of being too damn
dry that we get too conservative in
terms of pushing the rotation and we
fail because it's too wet if you're
failing cons what you want to do is
fail parts of the rotation when it's too
wet fail parts of the rotation when it's
too dry in most years they all work
pretty good we all we also harvested 100
Bush of wheat so uh 99 eight or
something like that average on the main
farm so we had a good year from that
standpoint crop insurance regulations
impact risks associated with different
rotational intensities and also make
sure that your crop insurance rules fit
what you're doing with cover crops so we
got a guy in Kansas that basically lost
his whole payment because he did a bunch
of stuff with cover crop and they came
out and
said that's not
approved there should be no need for a
ground engaging component to seed and
fertilize crops we should be able to
shoot them in the ground with something
like
this so all this St about trying to cut
residue and do all that kind of stuff if
we just have a seed in a thing that
looks like a gol tea and just shoot it
in the ground it'd be great go out there
with our floater and put it
on Ray talked about one straw
Revolution using clay seed ball same
idea seed Stakes would do the same thing
and basically what he's doing is he
spreads his seed balls
out drains the the rice fields spreads
the seed balls out for his wheat
crop the wheat crop takes off and grows
after the rice and he's before he
harvested the wheat he put seed seed
balls out grow cover crop and then he
throws his rice out and floods a field
and the rice grows I read the
book livestock integration will be
needed if if you're want a cycle
nutrients cows help it gives you better
nutrient Cycles it gives you more
rotational flexibility more crops you
can grow we need to work on automating
that and making a multispecies and we're
working or hope to be working on these
selfpropelled grazing cells but we have
the technology now you just have a cell
out there you call it up on your
smartphone and go how my cow's doing oh
looks like they're out of feed push a
button and the thing would move we could
do that now the technology is there
somebody says this makes sense
we've automated them in feed Lots we
haven't automated them in the field and
there's way less disease pressure and
stuff we kept them in the field it gives
us a chance with these
high price we have for land to get young
people back into the
business so best biomass digestor has
four legs and goes
move right and I like this one we're
soil testing and then they're going to
apply the fertilizer
right I couldn't resist that one that
was too good uh but here the Canadians
do a lot of this they SWA the residue
and and whatever and the reason they do
is they have they have had more BSE mad
cow so if you have a cow over 24 months
old is basically worthless in Canada and
for you guys that came to the conference
in year on several years ago we had guys
talking about doing this kind of thing
perennial sequence or perennial cover
crops will probably be necessary because
annual crops don't go deep enough to
bring the line back to the
surface okay in Australia they have a
huge problem with
this and that's where Colin sizes thing
works but I was in a sorghum field one
time where they thought it was drought
problem with sorghum but the only place
the Sorghum looked good was right around
the
tree and then Ray Ward can tell us what
that is what nutrient deficiency symptom
looks like drought
problems there you go see how good he is
so when we test it what the tree does is
it brings the potassium up and puts it
back at the surface so in high rainfall
areas that's our cycler in Prairie areas
it's a deep rooted grass because we
don't get as much rainfall that's enough
need a tree where it rains more they get
the rainfall in the winter time so what
happened is we had 100 parts per million
potassium around the tree five parts per
million where we're away from the tree
so the drought wasn't a drought it was a
potassium
deficiency I'll be D nutrient cycling
rotational flexibility building organic
matter we need to do all those things we
might if we're going to do fuel we might
want to
do biomass Fuel and our new building
we're building we're going to heat it
with solar wind and
biomass biomass only when we need to
because we like to keep organic matter
and feeder
cows the austr the Argentine used to
have
systems that were seven years of pasture
and seven years of grazing so here's
cover crops no cover crops but this
field would have been in seven years of
pasture and then probably about its
fifth year of of of crops look at the
soil
structure that's
1997 and then the Argentine government
outlawed the export of
beef and they said it was so the poor
people could afford to own bee to buy
beef because they atat twice as much
beef per capita as we do great place to
visit if you're a young single male guy
especially pretty girls wine and beef I
mean
it's doesn't get any better than that um
but Ruth said are they pretty and I said
yeah and but I said it's kind of like a
dog chasing a car deer I wouldn't know
what to do with it if I caught it anyway
so
but when they outlawed the the real
reason for out
outlawing the export of beef is they
wanted more soybeans because the way
they collect taxes in in Argentina is
they take 32% of the soybeans that leave
through the
port go to the government so we have the
IRS and all these rules and everything
right brick buildings cars computers
they got one guy an auger and a gun
but
anyway so everybody went to doing lots
of
soybeans because we can't do cows can't
do the pastures we're going to do
soybeans and I
finally in 2006 got to go back to the
same field because I've been there a
couple times I was noticing I thought
they were losing soil structure but
unless they went back to the same field
I couldn't tell you that's the same
field in 2006 that happened in 10
years soybeans on soybeans on soy beans
there's not enough carbon there's not
enough residue your carbon nitrogen
ratio is all screwed up you're just
going to totally destroy structure very
fast it's like doing tillage over and
over and over again and this is a plate
plate type structure here's one that
we're doing right now we have elala this
is our long-term 23-year corn field but
we planted alala in half of that and
we're keeping the elf alive and the corn
alive and so far so good but we'll find
out next spring so the idea is kind of
Colin SC is doing a warm season grass as
a
grazer like a looks like switch grass or
or big blue stem and then he grows
canola and wheat during the winter time
during the dormant
phase here during the dormant phase of
the
Corn the fall and the winter we're going
to have this perennial guy okay we'll
see if we can keep them both alive
organic matter is the most important
factor in determining the productivity
of soil small amount of organic matter
by weight has a big impact on for
space within all texture groups is we go
from 1 to 3% the available water
capacity doubles go to 4% at
60% your water does not hold as much
your soil does not hold as much water as
it did when Grandpa got here
because he's taking out the organic
matter so if you had a soil like on a a
soil web that says okay it holds 8 in
now it maybe holds six what's that mean
a rainfall makes you saturated
sooner and then when you get a crop
planted there you get dry sooner you
have less resiliency your bucket is
smaller the best thing to do is get a
bigger bucket okay the other thing that
happens is we might be changing carbon
dioxide level in a canopy because if
residu these cover crops that de
decompose after crop canopy is
established or the residue that decompos
them can feed carbon dioxide to
especially C3
plants cook and vth talked about that
perhaps some of the improved water use
efficiency results can be attributed to
enhanced carbon dioxide concentration so
here's an example of our you've seen
before probably but here's two rotations
that look almost exactly the same corn
pea winter wheat this one though has
another soybean in there so it's half
broad
leaves this one up here is only a third
broadleaf look at the difference in a
dry year 60 versus 29 with 7.9 Ines of
rain in from July to
July in 2006 in a good year 92 ver 57
that's when we had 23 in of rain here we
had .4 56 versus
28 that tells you the difference in
resiliency there's what it look like
this is the low residue rotation there
high residue rotation there that's what
it looks like in an aerial photo when
you take
off half of 150 Bush acre corn crop
you're taking off 50 pounds a acre of
Van 5 lbs of P 100 lb of K and 3,000 lb
of
carbon I had a guy last week we when I
was traveling to Montana somebody called
me on the phone wanted to buy my baales
that we had spread out to do some bail
grazing and stuff I'm going you can't I
it took me like 20 minutes to convince
him I didn't want to sell my damn
residue you can't have it you know like
well I'll pay you good for it you can't
have it don't you want to know how much
no you can't have
it a friend or guy from South Dakota no
tilling it's not about no till it's
about residue
doesn't have any
residue doesn't do any good to not do
tillage because it's all sealed up right
Ray it's all screwed up there there's no
residue it looks like Paul yaz's organic
thing where' the residue go Abdul took
it and he took the
roots along with it because in mlim
culture if you leave anything out there
belongs to the
community so you take it all and you put
it on your
semis or your straight trucks and
you and you take it to the building but
we laugh but that guy if that's the
residue he's going to feed to the goat
that's going to give milk to his
children it's not because he's a greedy
bastard that just wants a bigger
four-wheel drive
pickup okay there wouldn't be anybody in
this room that would do that
take the E out of e and take the T out
of
can't go to the South dakota.com and
we've got like a good thing for doing
rotations or different styles of
rotations that you might have fun
reading okay thank you
[Applause]